...
-Christian Saint-Palais,
êtes-vous devenu
avocat par effraction ?
Vous n'êtes pas
un enfant du sérail.
Vous vous décrivez
comme un rural à Paris.
-Oui, je crois que c'est
ce qui me caractérise beaucoup.
Je pense que j'ai apporté à Paris
des valeurs de la ruralité,
et je pense, vraiment,
que nous devrions
nous référer souvent à la ruralité
pour organiser nos vies
et notre groupe social.
Alors "par effraction",
je revendique quand même
d'avoir gagné ma place,
de l'avoir sans doute méritée,
mais disons que ça n'était pas
un destin tout à fait tracé,
si on peut parler de destin.
-De 2016 à 2021,
vous avez présidé l'association
des avocats pénalistes.
Pour un rural à Paris,
vous vous êtes bien débrouillé.
-C'est ma plus grande fierté.
-Oui ? Pourquoi ?
-Cette association a été créée
par des hommes et des femmes
que j'admirais
avant de devenir avocat.
Et quand je suis devenu avocat,
beaucoup sont devenus mes amis,
et ils m'ont élu pour être
à la tête de cette association
qui avait été créée
notamment par Hervé Temime,
et qui réunissait
Jean-Yves Le Borgne,
Pelletier, Mme Smadja,
Jacqueline Laffont, Haïk, Herzog.
-Les ténors du barreau.
-Oui, les très grands noms
du pénal.
-Comme D'Artagnan,
vous êtes natif du Béarn,
mais à défaut de manier l'épée,
vous êtes devenu,
à 20 ans, instituteur,
avant de faire des études
de droit.
Vous avez toujours eu
la défense dans la peau,
dès votre plus jeune âge.
Plus qu'un métier,
c'est une vocation,
c'est une mission ?
-Je pense que c'est une nature.
Les avocats pénalistes,
nous nous reconnaissons,
nous nous flairons.
Nous sommes différents,
mais je crois que nous réagissons
de la même façon, au même moment,
devant une injustice.
Et je pense
que dans les cours de récréation,
nous étions des enfants
qui réagissions à l'injustice.
Voilà pourquoi
je parle de nature.
Une très grande sensibilité,
exacerbée parfois,
à ce que nous considérons
comme des situations
qui ne devraient pas avoir lieu,
et où une personne
est stigmatisée, mise à l'écart.
Après, une vocation...
Quand j'étais enfant,
je jouais à l'avocat.
Mais je jouais aussi au curé,
pour prendre la parole,
donc finalement, peut-être
que j'aurais pu "mal" tourner.
-Regardez.
*-La cour !
*-L'audience est ouverte.
Veuillez vous asseoir.
-Il paraît que vous avez été
biberonné à cette émission,
"Messieurs les jurés",
diffusée sur la 2e chaîne
de la RTF dès 1974.
C'est à cette émission
que vous devez votre vocation,
ou à Gisèle Halimi qui défendait
le droit à l'avortement à Bobigny ?
-C'est en essayant de reconstruire
les choses que je pense
à ces images qui, d'après moi,
m'ont beaucoup marqué.
Gisèle Halimi,
nous devons être en 1973,
à Bobigny, et je me souviens
de cette solitude, si vous voulez,
c'est comme ça que je le percevais.
-C'était une réalité.
C'était une jeune femme seule.
-Oui, mais quand on connaît,
il y avait des groupes de soutien.
Je pense que je percevais
autour de moi, dans ma famille,
peut-être
une certaine désapprobation.
Et je me souviens être fasciné
par ce que je considérais être
un certain courage, la noblesse
d'être seul face à des forces
qui se mobilisent contre vous.
Et "Messieurs les jurés",
j'avais 10 ans,
puisque vous montrez cet épisode,
c'était une émission
que je regardais,
je crois j'ai toujours été
marqué par la solennité,
le silence.
Nous, les avocats,
nous sommes des bavards,
mais je suis très attaché
au silence.
Et vous voyez : "La cour !"
Silence.
"Maître, vous avez la parole",
c'est un moment très fort,
dans nos vies professionnelles.
"Maître, vous avez la parole",
le silence se fait,
avant que vous le meubliez.
Ces silences m'ont toujours fasciné.
-Vous avez commencé
dans le droit de la copropriété
et des baux commerciaux,
et vous avez plaidé
dans des cuisines
au milieu de champs,
et même sur un capot de voiture.
-Exact.
Ca, c'est le droit
de l'expropriation.
Et quand on plaide
de l'expropriation,
pour fixer l'indemnité,
on se rend sur place.
-Encore aujourd'hui ?
-Oui, absolument.
C'est la procédure.
Lorsqu'une maison est expropriée,
pour un ouvrage public,
pour faire passer une autoroute,
vous visitez la maison
avec le juge,
et si nous n'avions pas
le temps d'aller au tribunal,
on pouvait s'installer
autour de la table de la cuisine,
et plaider sur place.
J'ai plaidé parfois dans un champ
parce que c'était une propriété
agricole qui était expropriée,
où nous mesurions pour savoir
où étaient les canalisations,
si le terrain était constructible.
Pour un jeune, c'est très formateur.
-Encore aujourd'hui,
on plaide sur le terrain ?
-En principe,
on rejoint le tribunal,
mais par commodité,
si ça peut convenir à tout le monde,
pour éviter de revenir,
puisque nous l'avons déjà fait,
nous avons déjà échangé nos
arguments devant le juge, en bottes.
On peut conférer une solennité
quand même.
On réinvestit le champ judiciaire
en se disant :
"Nous prenons nos rôles
"et nous faisons les choses
comme il le faut."
-Un métier, une carrière,
c'est aussi le fruit
de hasards et de rencontres.
Celle, en 1995, avec le pénaliste
Jean-Yves Le Borgne,
a été déterminante.
C'est lui qui vous a ouvert
les portes du pénal ?
-Bien sûr.
Jean-Yves Le Borgne...
-Vous l'aimez.
-Mais oui !
Je l'aime beaucoup.
Il est devenu un ami.
C'était mon patron,
il m'a offert
de devenir son associé,
ça n'est pas rien comme démarche,
et nous avons cheminé ensemble,
lui m'apprenant tout ce que je sais.
C'est un des plus grands avocats.
J'hésite même un peu à le dire,
parce que tout de suite,
il va me dire :
"Mais qui sont donc les autres ?"
Daphné Roulier rit.
-Ils sont égomaniaques,
les avocats ?
-Certains le sont.
Mais là,
je le dis très amicalement.
C'est un des plus grands
avocats français,
et surtout, une générosité
extraordinaire, un pénaliste
comme il en existe peu,
une culture extraordinaire.
Je l'ai rejoint en 1995,
il m'a proposé
une association en 2000,
et nous sommes toujours ensemble,
nous cheminons ensemble.
-En 2004, vous êtes désigné
pour être l'avocat de Romain Dupuy,
un jeune schizophrène responsable
du meurtre de deux infirmières
à l'hôpital psychiatrique de Pau.
De là s'est nouée d'ailleurs
la question de la responsabilité
pénale des malades psychiatriques.
Cette affaire vous a longtemps
taraudé.
Pourquoi ?
-D'abord, c'était une affaire
dont on se souvient peut-être,
un garçon
qui avait tué une infirmière
et une aide-soignante,
et qui avait décapité
l'une des deux.
Cette affaire avait créé
une émotion considérable.
Ce garçon était atteint
d'une maladie psychiatrique
qui avait aboli son discernement.
Dans notre code pénal,
un homme qui a commis un crime,
quelle qu'en soit la gravité,
dont le discernement était aboli,
ne peut être condamné.
Il y a eu une polémique,
le président à ce moment-là
était Nicolas Sarkozy
qui soutenait que si
on prononçait un non-lieu,
c'est-à-dire il n'y a plus lieu
à poursuivre les investigations,
ça veut dire
que ça n'a pas eu lieu,
ce qui est vraiment
une aberration pour un juriste.
Ce dossier m'a préoccupé,
car l'avocat se pose
toujours la question :
"Serai-je à la hauteur
pour convaincre
"de ce que je considère
être juste dans cette défense
"et dans le traitement
de ce dossier ?"
Ensuite, ce qui peut tarauder,
c'est que ce garçon,
comme vous le savez peut-être,
est toujours aujourd'hui
en hôpital psychiatrique.
La question qui se pose
est celle de savoir
si la crainte qu'avait suscitée
ce crime à ce moment-là
ne perturbe pas
l'analyse sur sa situation.
Aujourd'hui, des confrères
ont pris le combat
pour sa liberté, le mènent
en multipliant les recours,
en exhortant les juges
à examiner sereinement
sa situation,
et ce qui me préoccupe,
bien sûr,
c'est qu'on ne lui réserve pas
le sort qu'il mériterait
de connaître.
L'hospitalisation par contrainte,
c'est aussi une situation
très difficile à vivre.
-L'affaire vous a aussi amené
à vous questionner
sur votre relation
aux médias et aux clients.
Elle a été un détonateur ?
-Cette affaire
a été très médiatisée.
Que pouvons-nous dire...
La question de l'avocat,
aussi, il faut bien le dire,
qu'il se préoccupe aussi
d'être choisi,
désigné par les clients.
Une affaire médiatique
lui permet une certaine exposition,
qui lui permet d'être connu.
C'est une préoccupation
que l'on peut admettre.
Il y a les grands principes,
et il y a aussi la réalité
du quotidien et la nécessité
d'être connu pour être choisi,
et ensuite, pour défendre.
Nous voulons absolument défendre.
Mais que puis-je faire qui ne soit
pas défavorable à sa défense ?
C'est cela, la question, en réalité.
Je ne dois m'exposer publiquement,
si je veux respecter ma mission,
qu'au service de sa défense.
C'est une vraie question.
Et ensuite, savoir le faire.
Vous êtes jeune,
sous cette pression,
vous n'avez pas encore
beaucoup d'expérience :
"Est-ce que je vais savoir faire
ce qu'il convient de faire ?"
Pour mon rapport aux médias,
c'était particulier,
et pour mon rapport au client,
là, c'est la situation
particulière qui vous unit
à quelqu'un dont on vous dit
que le discernement
n'est pas total.
Et pourtant, je ne suis
que le porteur de parole
de celui qui m'a désigné
pour le défendre.
Alors c'est difficile
de savoir si je suis exactement
en phase avec ce qu'il souhaiterait
que je dise pour lui.
Je ne parle pas de lui précisément,
je ne suis plus le conseil
de ce dossier,
mais de manière générale, voilà
les questions qui peuvent se poser.
-D'autres questions
se sont posées
dans l'affaire de Me Karim Achoui,
que vous avez défendu,
condamné à sept ans de prison
pour complicité d'évasion
avant d'être acquitté en 2010.
Cette affaire a été
un jalon important.
Ce procès a-t-il été l'occasion
pour vous d'expliquer ce qu'est
votre métier ? J'ai le sentiment
qu'il y a une incompréhension
et un malentendu
sur le rôle de l'avocat pénaliste
et sur la fonction même
du procès pénal.
-Oui, peut-être pour moi l'affaire
la plus importante dans ma carrière,
dont je suis le plus heureux.
J'avais défendu
en première instance un garçon
auquel on reprochait
la participation
à l'évasion d'Antonio Ferrara,
qui avait été acquitté,
et j'ai défendu
Karim Achoui en appel.
C'était très important pour moi.
C'était l'occasion
d'expliquer notre métier,
et comment la proximité
que l'on reprochait à Karim Achoui
avec celui qui s'était évadé
de la prison de Fresnes,
cette proximité n'est pas
forcément une complicité.
Bien sûr, chacun le sait,
tout le monde le dit,
les magistrats vous disent
dans les colloques :
"Bien sûr que nous le savons."
Mais c'est une proximité
qui dérange.
On reprochait à Karim Achoui
des visites en prison,
une proximité,
dans le but, lui disait-on,
de transmettre des informations
qui allaient permettre
la réalisation du projet d'évasion
qui était nourri
par toute une bande bien organisée.
Il a été in fine acquitté,
je pense
que parce qu'en le défendant,
nous avons réussi
à expliquer à des jurés
ce que pouvait être
cette position très singulière
de l'avocat pénaliste, très proche,
y compris physiquement,
du criminel, et cependant,
avec la distance
qui fait que l'avocat n'est pas
le complice du criminel.
-Vous avez été l'avocat, entre
autres, du braqueur Rédoine Faïd,
de l'ancien directeur de campagne
de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012,
Jérôme Lavrilleux, poursuivi
dans l'affaire Bygmalion,
du rappeur-acteur JoeyStarr,
de Nabilla,
ou encore, dans un autre genre,
d'Alexandre Benalla,
l'ex-chargé de mission de l'Elysée.
C'est pour le moins éclectique.
Qu'est-ce qui vous conduit
à accepter
ou refuser un dossier ?
Vous arrive-t-il d'en refuser ?
-Oui, oui.
-Pour quel motif ?
-D'abord, je le redis
parce que pour moi,
c'est essentiel :
nous sommes choisis.
Et la première question,
quand même :
"Vais-je savoir faire
ce que celui qui me choisit
"souhaite que je fasse
pour sa défense ?"
Parce que parfois,
nous avons des divergences.
Et là, ce n'est pas tellement
vous qui refusez,
c'est celui qui est venu
vers vous qui se dit :
"Je n'ai pas trouvé
le bon pour faire
"ce à quoi j'aspirais,
ce dont je rêvais."
Après, nous avons
des considérations très triviales.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Parfois, on vous dit :
"Je souhaite que vous plaidiez
pour moi à telle date,
"en septembre 2023", et vous ouvrez
assez classiquement votre agenda.
Et Donc, vous ne pouvez pas...
Et pourquoi ne pas aborder
aussi le coût d'une défense,
puisque nous parlons
de mon métier.
C'est aussi un coût pour celui
qui choisit un avocat.
-Il vous arrive
de le faire "pro bono" ?
-Bien sûr.
D'abord, nous sommes
parfois sollicités par ceux qui sont
poursuivis pour des escroqueries,
ils savent tromper leur avocat,
parfois en le flattant :
"Vous êtes le meilleur,
je vous donnerai une contrepartie",
et on se fait avoir,
on est le dernier escroqué.
Mais plus sérieusement,
nous avons une fidélité
pour nos anciens clients.
-Client un jour, client toujours.
-Oui.
-L'an passé,
vous vous êtes à la fois retrouvé
à défendre la famille
du père Hamel,
assassiné en 2016
à Saint-Etienne-du-Rouvray,
et Yassine Atar,
frère cadet d'Oussama Atar,
le cerveau des attentats
du 13 novembre,
pour qui vous avez plaidé
l'acquittement.
La question peut sembler idiote,
mais comment passe-t-on
dans la même journée
du banc de la défense
à celui de l'accusation ?
Vous défendez des hommes,
et non leurs crimes,
mais cette facétie du calendrier
ne vous a-t-elle pas contraint
à une certaine forme
de dissociation ?
-La question
est très importante,
et pour nous,
c'est une question
assez fondamentale.
Je ne vous cache pas
que lorsque les calendriers
se sont télescopés
et que j'ai été convoqué
pour les assises
de ceux à qui on reprochait
la participation
au meurtre du père Hamel,
j'étais déjà impliqué
dans le Bataclan,
et je me suis posé
la question, c'est vrai :
"Ceux qui m'ont accordé
leur confiance
"vont-ils accepter que je passe
d'une salle à l'autre",
car c'est ce que je faisais,
je passais d'une salle à l'autre,
pour quitter le banc
de la défense d'une salle
et rejoindre celui
des parties civiles dans l'autre.
La question, je la comprends.
"Puis-je faire confiance à cet homme
"qui, dans l'autre salle,
plaide pour l'acquittement
"d'un homme poursuivi
pour terrorisme ?"
Ils ont eu l'intelligence
de comprendre
que tout ça n'était pas
impossible.
Ce n'est pas simple,
mais il faut,
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que nous mesurions toujours
notre parole publique,
il faut de la cohérence.
Je défends l'Etat de droit
de la même façon
quand je suis sur le banc
de la défense au procès du Bataclan
que sur les bancs des parties
civiles dans le procès Hamel.
-La défense post-MeToo.
Vous êtes
le conseil de Jean-Jacques Bourdin.
Il y a beaucoup
de questions de prescription,
principe que vous défendez
ardemment.
La prescription est devenue
le symbole de l'injustice
par excellence.
Beaucoup y voient
la négation des actes dénoncés,
des souffrances endurées.
Que dites-vous à ces victimes
qui ont besoin d'être entendues ?
-Je comprends ce besoin,
mais nous avons une législation,
une loi, qui n'a pas été
adoptée à la sauvette.
Nous avons fixé des règles,
nous avons beaucoup allongé
les délais de prescription,
mais depuis les années 1990,
nous réfléchissons collectivement
sur la possibilité d'allonger
les délais de prescription,
et de poursuivre plus tard
les agressions et crimes sexuels.
Quand nous adoptons des lois,
c'est après des réflexions
qui réunissent les professionnels.
Avocats, magistrats, psychologues,
associations de victimes.
Nous avons tous dit, par la loi,
que certes, nous allions étendre,
mais que quand même,
il y avait une limite.
Parce que nous savons
que nous ne pouvons pas
bien juger
au terme d'un certain délai,
et que parfois, la réponse
judiciaire qui est de dire :
"Je ne peux pas condamner
cet homme mis en cause,
"donc je le relâche
ou je l'acquitte",
est très violente
pour celle ou celui qui a mené
le parcours de plaignant
visant à obtenir la condamnation.
Nous disons : "Ce n'est pas cela
qui va vous réparer.
Et ça n'est pas non plus mépriser
un plaignant que de lui dire :
"Notre loi ne permet plus
de faire les choses."
Ce à quoi il faut penser...
J'ai été aussi,
dans mon parcours, instituteur.
Je pense que voilà
la meilleure occasion,
le bon moment,
l'école primaire,
le collège, la formation,
pour dire :
"Voilà comment
vous devez identifier
"les agressions sexuelles
sur votre corps."
Il faut que nous arrivions
à ce que ces révélations
se fassent plus tôt.
Je ne dis pas : "Elle n'avait
qu'à le faire plus tôt",
comme on l'a entendu
de philosophes...
-Mme Badinter.
-Oui.
Mais je ne parle pas
aussi cruellement,
parce que le propos était
excessivement, d'après moi...
-Méprisant ?
-Cruel.
Je l'ai perçu comme méprisant.
Bien sûr.
Je sais très bien cette difficulté
à dire les choses, à révéler
un viol ou une agression.
C'est ça que nous devons travailler.
-A la libération de la parole ?
-A la libération de la parole,
à la meilleure écoute ensuite,
mais d'abord
à la libération de la parole.
-Beaucoup de vos confrères
font le lien entre démocratie
et défense pénale.
L'avocat, c'est un maillon
essentiel de la démocratie,
c'est celui qui met
le pied dans la porte ?
-Oui, je crois que...
La machine judiciaire
est une machine étatique.
Y a des pouvoirs considérables.
C'est légitime.
On veut découvrir
les auteurs d'infraction,
on est donc dotés
de moyens extraordinaires
pour rentrer dans la vie privée,
placer sur écoute,
perquisitionner,
et cette machine est bien rodée
pour que les juges compétents
prennent le relais de la police
et organisent un procès.
Et le procès, en principe,
est pour juger
celui qui est dans le box,
dont l'accusation est persuadée
qu'il est coupable,
et ça doit rouler
jusqu'à la condamnation.
L'avocat est porteur
simplement d'un petit intérêt
personnel, particulier.
Il faut avoir conscience
que cette machine
est puissante, elle est dotée
des moyens de l'Etat,
elle peut broyer, et donc,
il faut essayer de s'immiscer.
Un avocat pénaliste
ne doit jamais être trop poli.
doit voler un peu sa place.
Elle ne lui est pas
immédiatement donné,
il doit la prendre,
c'est ça aussi l'expérience,
de respecter la règle,
mais cependant, de se lever,
et donc,
de faire vivre des règles
qui parfois peuvent être oubliées
par préoccupation d'efficacité.
Et les victimes, est-ce que
ce ne serait pas les mépriser
que de laisser
trop de place à la défense,
que de ne pas
donner satisfaction
à ce qui a généré
tant d'émotion ?
Non, l'avocat est là
pour rappeler les principes
et dire
combien c'est fondamental
de faire bénéficier du doute,
d'offrir un temps nécessaire
à la défense,
c'est un problème que nous avions
par exemple au procès du Bataclan.
Beaucoup de victimes
veulent parler,
mais les hommes qui vont être jugés
doivent aussi pouvoir s'exprimer,
et le barreau est souvent uni
pour ce respect des principes.
Car nous savons que ça n'est pas
pour défendre les salauds,
puisque certains voient
ceux qui sont dans le box ainsi,
c'est pour nous défendre,
nous, citoyens,
citoyens au quotidien,
qui pouvons être un jour
mis en cause dans des procédures,
et nous serons heureux qu'aient
été préservés ces principes
qui nous permettent
de nous défendre.
-Bientôt la fin
du jury populaire.
Nos concitoyens n'ont plus
confiance en la justice,
ils ne pourront bientôt plus
y participer.
Vous le déplorez ?
-Je le regrette
très profondément.
C'était un acquis révolutionnaire.
Symboliquement, c'est important.
Et nous nous plaignons
de la distance
que prennent nos concitoyens
avec la justice,
de cette méfiance,
et même défiance avec la justice.
-Croissante.
-Oui.
Le fait que les jurés
participent à la justice,
ça permettait aux citoyens
de se rapprocher de cette justice,
de rentrer chez eux et de dire :
"Il y a des magistrats
qui mouillent la chemise."
Ca nourrit le respect à l'égard
de l'institution judiciaire,
et la complexité
de la décision judiciaire.
-Justement, dans son ouvrage,
"De la démocratie en Amérique",
Alexis de Tocqueville notait
que le jury sert à donner
à l'esprit de tous les citoyens
une partie des habitudes
de l'esprit du juge,
et ces habitudes sont celles
qui préparent le mieux le peuple
à être libre.
Autrement dit,
c'est un instrument de citoyenneté
qui permet de s'approprier
et de trancher un problème
en ayant conscience des difficultés
inhérentes à l'acte de juger ?
-Absolument.
Si vous recevez des jurés,
si on lit les témoignages de jurés,
vous voyez combien
ils se disent sortis enrichis
d'une telle expérience.
C'est ça qui est formidable
pour moi, c'est qu'ils vont
réintégrer notre groupe social,
notre Etat de droit,
en sachant qu'on ne peut pas
porter un jugement trop rapide
sur celui qui est mis en cause,
d'abord parce qu'il n'est pas
forcément coupable,
et ce n'est pas non plus
parce qu'il est coupable
d'un acte monstrueux
que lui-même ne révèle pas
une part d'humanité
et qu'il ne mérite pas qu'on essaye
de comprendre son passage à l'acte.
C'est très important.
-On a le sentiment
qu'au fond, la justice est bradée
sur l'autel du rendement,
une logique de marché,
de flux tendu.
-Il y a un grand stock.
C'est un mot beaucoup utilisé,
le "stock" des dossiers.
Et il faut résorber
le stock des dossiers.
Il est difficile
de réunir une cour d'assises
composée de jurés,
car il faut les convoquer,
il faut avoir
les salles nécessaires,
et cela peut prendre du temps.
On aurait pu dire :
"On va doter davantage ce poste-là
et on va multiplier
les cours d'assises
avec les jurés.
On a dit :
"Non, on va économiser."
Et on a dit : "On va désormais
juger comme en correctionnelle,
"comme les délits, des crimes,
en supprimant les jurés,
"et en composant aujourd'hui
de cinq magistrats professionnels."
Et dans quelques années...
-Il y en aura plus que trois.
-Bien sûr.
Quand on a créé
la cour d'assises spéciale
pour le terrorisme,
on nous a dit : "On supprime
les jurés, ils ont trop peur."
C'est faux.
Ils ont une mission citoyenne
et pouvaient nous rejoindre
pour juger les crimes terroristes.
On a dit : "On va vous mettre
sept magistrats.
"C'est vraiment
une grande collégialité."
Quelques années plus tard,
nous n'en avons plus eu que cinq.
Aujourd'hui, à la cour
criminelle départementale,
vous avez cinq magistrats.
Il y en
aura trois dans quelques années.
Oui, nous avons
un problème de finances.
Oui, un effort considérable,
avec une augmentation
de 8 % du budget, a été réalisé
cette année, mais on n'a pas
forcément affecté l'argent
là où on aurait pu l'affecter.
Nous aurons les problèmes
pour meubler la cour criminelle
départementale rapidement,
parce que nous n'avons pas
de magistrats.
On vous dit : "Nous prendrons
des avocats honoraires."
Des pis-aller.
La justice
sera bien rendue, attention.
J'ai toujours dit
que les magistrats savent faire.
Donc les magistrats rendront
la justice, et je ne prétends pas
qu'ils vont condamner
davantage d'innocents
que l'aurait fait un jury populaire.
Mais nous perdons en solennité,
nous perdons en adhésion du peuple
au rendu de la justice,
et ça, c'est une perte
absolument considérable.
Il faut pas non plus
se cacher la réalité,
il y a des mouvements
qui militent depuis longtemps
pour la suppression
du jury populaire.
Vous en avez dans la magistrature,
et sans doute au barreau.
Beaucoup d'éléments
qui vous disent :
"Comment ces gens
peuvent-ils juger ?"
Il faut pas négliger ce regard
extrêmement méprisant qui est porté.
D'ailleurs,
les magistrats se disent :
"J'ai eu une formation
particulière difficile,
"des concours élitistes
pendant des années,
"et des types tirés au hasard
vont pouvoir remplir
"la même mission que moi,
spontanément, sans formation ?"
C'est peut-être pour certains
une question assez insoluble.
Mais il y a en tout cas
ce mouvement
qui existe depuis longtemps
de supprimer,
finalement, le peuple.
Et restons entre nous.
Pas simplement les magistrats.
Les magistrats et certains membres
du barreau se disent :
"C'est une réforme
pas si compliquée que ça."
Et c'est un grand avocat pénaliste
qui la porte désormais.
-Dupond-Moretti,
le garde des Sceaux.
-C'est très douloureux pour moi.
Je n'aurais jamais imaginé.
Je savais qu'il ne pourrait pas
renverser la table,
puisque cette réforme
était déjà lancée,
mais je n'imaginais pas
qu'il allait accélérer le mouvement
et finalement
signer l'arrêt de mort
de la cour d'assises,
puisqu'à terme...
-Vous vivez cela
comme une trahison ?
-Ecoutez, je ne voudrais pas
employer ces mots-là,
c'est un homme pour lequel
j'ai une admiration immense.
C'est un des plus grands
avocats du 20e siècle,
et je lui suis
tellement reconnaissant
pour tout ce qu'il a
apporté à la défense.
-Mais vous jugez cette réforme
attentatoire
aux droits des citoyens.
-Oui.
Je la trouve attentatoire
à l'Etat de droit,
à la démocratie,
la participation des citoyens.
Et qu'un avocat pénaliste
qui a autant fréquenté
la cour d'assises...
-Qui s'est autant battu
pour le maintien.
-Je ne veux pas
parler de trahison,
mais je constate
les dégâts que peuvent faire
une carrière politique
sur la force des convictions.
-Une dernière question.
Vous arpentez beaucoup les allées
des cimetières,
notamment celui de Montparnasse.
La fréquentation des morts
inspire vos plaidoiries,
nourrit vos réflexions ?
-Je ne dirais pas cela,
mais quand vous êtes
fils de paysan,
vous restez toujours
fils de paysan.
Nous savons où nous sommes nés,
et nous savons
où nous reposerons.
Le cimetière est un lieu
que nous fréquentons beaucoup.
Donc c'est vrai
que j'y retrouve le calme,
c'est propice à la méditation,
et puis y sont enterrés,
notamment à Montparnasse,
de très grandes figures.
J'aime cette confrontation
silencieuse avec ces figures.
Elles me permettent
de m'apaiser
et d'y trouver les moments
de méditation nécessaires
pour rentrer ensuite
dans l'arène judiciaire.
-Merci.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...